hey what's up my name is samuel leeds
i'm a property investor i also train
a lot of other people to become property
investors i'm with my man chris [ __ ]
right and chris jaffa's got 13 hmos that
he controls
he's on the academy chris you're
carrying it man thank you very much so
this property this isn't yours right
no this is the property we source for
our investor he sourced it
packaged it he's project managing it
it's a brr
hmo six beds on suites show us
everything chris let's go around
greg so this is room number one this is
room number one it's uh
it's gonna be a six bed all ensuite uh
hmo
uh so this this was the front reception
room
yeah here's something interesting chris
i often say you turn a living room into
a reception room by just putting a bed
in there
not the case with this room no we've had
to do a few things obviously
build the ensuite say the fireplace out
obviously you'll get five doors
into connecting smoke alarms but this is
not just a hmo this is a brr
hmo right yes the the end the end the
the how it was packaged together was it
was bought cheap we're gonna do the work
on it and then its end value is gonna be
either pull out almost all your money
leaving very little in yeah
and then break it out for a fortune and
then generate over two thousand pound
girls a month i mean what what are these
um
what's this area like for room
rentability uh it's
it's it's blue collar blue collar
workers yeah uh so they're gonna do your
dummy ads
we did a dummy add-on spare room we
contacted a few hmos
who were up and running in the area just
to check what's going on
and the feedback that came back from
them was it's
it's difficult in certain aspects but
where you're located because it's so
close to the town centre
no troubles all day long right they were
fighting over
who to choose they were saying like we
want you i i love the fact that you've
put these um
partition balls in that presumably this
will be an ensuite right
yes we've managed to we managed to
manipulate the floor space enough to get
every room as an ensuite
yeah great some some jb poke for the
smaller rooms but
i feel like now in 2020 especially in an
area that's a little bit
more working class you kind of want
ensuites because otherwise you're going
to attract the wrong kind of tenants
and times have changed i contradict what
i used to say four or five years ago
now i think it really helps having on
sweets and especially
i mean how much how much does this cost
is partition water but it's peanuts
it's peanuts yeah i mean for the ability
that we've got to come in here it's it's
mostly just day-rated materials
yeah so you're probably talking a few
hundred pounds right to get a
maximum maximum so check that out a few
hundred pounds
to get a wall belt and then for an
ensuite i know how much ensuite's cost
you're probably talking
2 000 pounds max to have a shower toilet
sink ensuite
so it doesn't cost that much but then
you're going to push the value right up
so
yeah great are they all big size like
this there is yeah we'll take it through
there's one smaller room
that we've had to be crafty with and the
rest of all their lot medium to large
jiggery poker here top jiggery look at
this
so this is the partition wall we have to
create this was
reception room number two because that
first bedroom was reception we won this
was reception room two
yeah so we created the partition wall in
here and then built an ensuite at the
back
but most people that would see this room
like he was before would think oh that
couldn't be a bedroom because there's
because people have to walk through the
road but you're thinking no no
you can for a few hundred pounds
build a wall right get that partition
these walls are different to these walls
these walls are
brick walls these walls are stud walls
costs
cost next to nothing so this is going to
be a bedroom and
another space great what was the
situation with
when you bought this pipe works boiler
electric was it all shot or was it was
it actually okay no they were
they were fine they the electrics is
compliant we've also had to
add additional spurs into the main
distribution board
and the plumbing was it's gonna be a bit
of an issue
not an issue it's a it's a bigger cost
because we have to get all the waste
pipes put in all the pipe putting in
the central heating there's a gas combi
boiler already we're gonna upgrade that
so it can cope with the extra six
ensuites
but uh yeah it's like a full refurb this
is
everything what's the cost of the total
refurb uh
when we packaged the deal we anticipated
it to being 40 000 pounds
at the moment uh looking back on what
we've done and how we're calculating
things
i would expect this to finish around the
42.43
that's not bad 43 000 for a full refurb
like this
honestly not bad at all so this is the
communal roof in here
so again trying to keep trying to keep
the properties in a
an appealing to create demand for the
people
we can't just turn every room into a
bedroom uh for us
could we we have a bunch of hmos we have
across chester north wales and liverpool
yeah we find listening to the tenants uh
it helps i'm maximizing it where they've
got just bedrooms and nowhere to
socialize
it's it's changing they don't want that
anymore really they prefer to have
somewhere they
it's always nice that's interesting
because i think it depends on the area
yeah
in birmingham they don't care about
community rooms they just sit on their
ipads
in their bedroom with super fast wi-fi
that's all they want so it's really
interesting so this is going to be a
communal area
presumably this will just remain in the
kitchen and this is going to be the
kitchen yes
great so it's going to have uh
to keep it compliant so we've got the
single sinks we're putting a dishwasher
in
uh and the hm officer came around during
the week and she gave up
all the ticks for everything we need to
do what would be what were the ceilings
like before did you have any issues
planning just yeah it was just not very
nice
uh this is an extension that was put on
previously so
that's why the roof slopes towards the
back end okay so that's the reason it
slows this we're just trying to make
prep it so it can be skinned so it's
nice and smooth
yeah because before that it was grease
stained horrible and
nasty just not nice did you have did you
have an abstract check did you have any
issues there
we didn't carry out an individual
asbestos check but when we had the
builders come around
and the roof was because we had the roof
done they came and
the areas they looked at that getting
replaced there was no asbestos
right so downstairs you've got you did
have
three reception rooms it was all badly
laid out but you turned it into
reception room
kitchen two double en-suite rooms yeah
and we've got another
four upstairs let's go and see those
yeah
so we're going to create this was the
master
bathroom initially yeah with a bedroom
in there we're going to create the
partition wall here to create a fire
door and this is all going to be one
room
so that's massive room it's the master
master mastermind
if i was
yep yeah everything's getting full how
full house is getting plastered
yeah the flask is getting plastic we're
just getting the boards ready
prepping it so it's ready yeah great
nice very big
very solid inside of the house so this
is bedroom number four
again a nice large size with uh
ensuite so literally every single room
because of the size of it you've just
been putting on sweet rooms well when we
looked at the floor plans initially it
was just
our eyes lit up it was almost like wow
these
look the dimensions you think you're
going to feel there chris because you're
the master of jiggery poker
most people would look at would look at
floor plans
and they wouldn't know what to do with
him although i i always find these days
the stages always get the floor plans
wrong
oh yes it's like way off they're not
even
they didn't even consider that extension
at the back that wasn't on the floor
plan
so initially the layouts were completely
different so what
we thought we were turning up to do had
to change where we viewed it
because it didn't didn't match up but as
you can see when you come through it
there's still
large reception rooms there's still
large rooms on the top floor as well
sometimes though if you're buying a
house you've got to come out
and measure it you cannot rely i've
known people though
that are uneducated see chris is
educated christian on the academy so he
knows his stuff
but i've honestly known people that buy
a house
based on the floor plans they're turning
into hmo but the estate
has said the rooms are slightly bigger
than they are and suddenly they can't
get a license no you're stuck
that's what happens tell me chris
this i was saying anyone can be a
property investor property investing is
simple okay
however this is technical isn't it it's
very it's quite complex
from the start to the finish definitely
it's more
uh complex you first think about because
when you factor in
all the the figures initially to make it
stuck uh the end value to make sure that
you've got the exit sorted out your
comparables your due diligence to make
everything
just managing the builders the builders
the whole build itself
yeah it's the costs the timelines the
everything that's involved in that so so
you've you're managing this so you've
packaged it you've sourced it you found
how did you
how did you find this deal how did you
find it uh we found it on rightmove
it was uh they found the right move and
it was
in such a bad state they were saying
they needed a quick sale so straight
away i was thinking well they must be
you know motivated to sell it so i
thought
we'll find out what's going on with it
more you looked into it the more the
floor plans added up and this and
you did the due diligence and it's
thinking this is a great property yeah
that's a good thing so it was right move
spoke to them
we almost lost it on the 11th hour uh
because
again with the auction they wanted they
still wanted to go to austin
but whilst we were carrying out all the
surveys for the investor uh
they were still proceeding with that if
we could get it done in time then we
could have it and it was i think it was
half an hour before the auction started
uh we we got it great closed clothes
that's the thing you've got to sometimes
get act quick
yeah you've got to get you've got to
make things happen quicker i think as a
property investor as an entrepreneur
speed i mean i mean just about every
deal that's been worth doing
that i've done i almost lost it at one
point and a lot of the best deals i
never bought because someone else beat
me to it
yeah we're finding that's the case at
the moment we're
getting picked to the post almost on a
few deals because of that
people are coming now with all your
packages all your documents ready
basically
yeah proof of that paper funds id
decision and principle
at least you can turn up to review and
if you do want to last week last week i
don't know if ben told you about a
property just down the road from here in
liverpool
great development opportunity half an
hour
too late with our offer really that's
quite slight oh anyway show me the other
couple rooms
so yeah these last rooms this is the
this is the master jiggery pokery as i
say
uh you are the man so
this room here was a tiny box room so if
you
if you look from this this wall here
this wall
this was one room yeah so this was
obviously too small
to be compliant so it was literally just
that that's it you can touch the walls
from side to side obviously yeah you're
in so that's like
an office or a cocked room yeah exactly
how on earth have you what's going on
here chris so we've knocked the walls
down
and pushed in to the next room because
this next room
was large enough to have the space
borrowed and for both rooms to be
compliant
uh so we have the bed going in here the
bed's going to go this way
i see what you've done so you've taken
the whole room back a couple feet
maybe three feet but then that bit's
going to be ensuite yeah that bit's
going to be sort of a bet
okay bedside cabinet and presumably that
room can afford to just
have a little bit nicked from it yes
definitely we've uh
managed to make this into a i think it's
six point seven meters squared so
we're cutting it fine just the right way
it's uh
regulations lots of light though yeah
natural light windows windows were
already double glazed
yeah and ensuite again yeah
and in the final room and room number
six
so this is the final double en-suite
room
so it's it is decent
and then you've got a big ensuite very
long large you're gonna have to
base coat this yeah after basically
that's one of the problems we
we saw when we first viewed it it was a
repointing
yeah i see that so we accounted for that
in the initial uh costings but
when the roof has come out he's saying
look it didn't need more than that
so that has pushed the costs up a little
bit which is why we've gone from 40. you
know
40 to 43 000 is not bad
and and you're what i think you said you
were one week behind schedule
so far yes not halfway through we're
halfway through uh and it's one week
not bad i like it so you literally
your packaging deals your selling deals
you're controlling properties you've got
rental rents
you've got your fingers in a lot of pies
buddy i'm busy man yeah so
i started off doing events and rent and
i systemized that where we had a
property manager and a lessons manager
in place
yeah it's allowed me to step away from
that and look into doing something else
set up the deal sourcing business so
we've slowly built
an investor list with this and now we're
working with a handful of investors who
are trying to build portfolios with them
yeah so this is one of them this is one
of the projects we've got going on
and you know what you've been doing so
well you've been posting your what
you've been doing you've been posting on
instagram
you've been on winners on a wednesday
yeah how's all that working out for you
it's it's it's good it's a i must admit
it
i know you need to get out more i do do
a lot i try and do videos of my
experience
where did this where did this lady come
from the investor uh instagram
there we go so you're putting yourself
out there you're posting
you're coming on my show on my youtube
show right now but that's what it's
about
having a good product or service finding
someone that needs that
and making yourself known and bringing
the two together so i like it
this was bought for a hundred and
fourteen thousand hundred and fourteen
thousand
forty three thousand is gonna be the
total refurb cost yes
so all in you're talking 140
plus 43. so all you're talking one five
seven i knew that figure i just didn't
want to say it
one five seven uh end value what's the
end value you're gonna be able to
estimated minimum of 200. a minimum of
200 which means you can then refinance
pull the vast majority of your money
back out
room rentals what we're talking about
hey with the ensuite we're talking about
100 pounds
100 pounds per week per week times that
by
52 that means 5 200 per year divide that
by 12 that means 433 per month
per room per room there's six rooms
so you're talking 2 600 bang on yeah for
the
it estimated yeah so so this is going to
be given
once even once you're paying the
mortgage payments it's going to be must
be cleaning what at least
at least a grand it's over a thousand
pounds here so the idea is obviously as
you've just gone through then is
it will be refinanced to pull out the
vast majority if not all of the money
now you've got a whole bunch of rent
rent to hmos you've got some renter
service accommodations
yes i i've got an hour or so right now i
want you to show me
yeah your best couple of properties that
you've got let's get around and uh
tell us the story but see that's the
thing chris is doing well
you know why chris is doing well i see
where christine worked because he's got
the knowledge and he's taking massive
action and he's putting himself out
there
so mad respect chris chris when did you
when did you join the academy
uh last august he joined the academy
last august
was it a good decision chris it's paid
for itself
pay for itself there we are there we are
let's go